every year thousands of students from
all over the world opt to study in
nations other than their own for a
variety of reasons many of them cite job
advancement higher pay and lifestyle
changes as the reasons for traveling to
foreign countries
however making this decision of studying
abroad is not that easy you'll have to
carry out thorough research about which
country is best suited for you and what
prospects it has to offer and to assist
you with that we bring you this video on
best countries to study abroad in this
session we'll explore the factors that
are commonly referred to while choosing
the country to study abroad and after
that we'll look at the top 4 countries
for abroad education so make sure you
stay back until the end of this video
first let's dive into the parameters for
selecting the best country for studying
abroad
education is the greatest transforming
instrument in the world shaping not just
individuals but also societies no matter
in which corner of the world we live in
education should be given prime
importance as it help us gain new
knowledge progress in life and build a
better world for tomorrow
education also makes us think and behave
more rationally
though education is acknowledged and
valued in many nations throughout the
world a few countries stand out if we
attempt to focus on what constitutes the
finest education system in the world
their education systems are not only of
great quality but many of them also have
certain distinguishing features that set
them apart for example the united states
is one of the most popular destinations
for students worldwide the reason is
high quality education world-class
faculty and cutting-edge infrastructure
and facilities according to qs word
university ranking report the united
states is considered to have better
educational system since 28 universities
from this country rank among the top
hundred universities globally
the united kingdom is the second best
country for quality education 16
universities from united kingdom rank in
top 100 universities worldwide the
institutions from the uk hold strong
brand identity university of oxford
university of cambridge imperial college
of london university of edinburgh london
school of economics and political
sciences hold a strong value in
education industry
the next factor that matters a lot is
the student acceptance rate
this is one of the foremost concern for
students who wish to study abroad
everyone faces the difficulty of
assimilating into a completely different
environment culture traditions and
customs despite putting in a ton of
efforts to become acquainted with the
culture
acceptance remains a major goal for
individuals in recent times students
have become little skeptical about
countries such as australia uk and italy
the reason behind this is the past event
of racism and anti-migrant sentiments
according to a survey done by a human
rights department in australia 85
percent of respondents believe that
racism is the biggest current issue in
australia
you can observe the same scenario in
united kingdom as well events like
brexit and anti-migrant sentiment in uk
have led to apprehensiveness among
students studying abroad
besides that students are various
countries such as france even though it
is regarded as a top study destination
since the major university programs in
this country are taught in french
language the next and most important
factor in selecting a country to study
abroad is budget
students on a tight budget always
prioritize germany but it is not simple
to get into any of the public
universities because competition is
fierce furthermore nordic countries are
regarded as economical study location
for international students countries
such as norway and poland are available
to everyone irrespective of their
nationality
students will only have to pay for
specialized courses in these countries
whereas there is no tuition fee in
germany if you get selected by a public
university
finally the last factor to look into is
return on investment
return on investment is simple ratio
that divides the net profit or loss from
an investment by its cost
because it is expressed as a percentage
you can compare the effectiveness or
profitability of your investment
in this scenario one way to look at roi
is the amount of time it takes to recoup
your investment in education
for masters european institutions
generally have one year master's degree
whereas u.s institutions have two years
masters degree it is definitely less
expensive to study in europe in the
present scenario germany for example
should be the ideal choice if one is
looking at getting the maximum return on
his investment
because germany provides free education
even for international students one more
country that has recently become very
popular is island island offers a
one-year program and has become the
european capital of iit inspiring many
students to look at the country for
higher education
to emphasize this point further consider
this scenario for mba students doing a
one year european mba would get more
return for their bucks as they have
spent only one year courses fee plus
potential employment loss this is the
reason why instant mba is rated the
highest on value for money versus other
prestigious schools like harvard or
stanford
on that note let's discover the top four
countries for pursuing abroad education
based on the factors we have just
discovered
the fourth country on our list is
australia
australia promotes innovation creativity
and independent thinking throughout its
universities international students in
australia highlight that their education
is challenging fun and rewarding besides
that 8 universities out of 39 australian
universities rank among top 100
institutes globally
australian national university
university of melbourne university of
sydney university of new south wales and
university of queensland are the top
five universities in australia
now let's talk about why we have listed
australia at the fourth position the
main reason behind that is the budget
associated with education in australia
the average tuition fee for
undergraduate programs in australia is
around 24 000 australian dollars which
turns out to be almost 18 048 us dollars
similarly if you are looking to pursue a
postgraduate degree in australia then
the average tuition cost is around 32
000 australian dollars
that's not the end of expenses you'll
have to think about living expenses as
well the average monthly living expense
in australia for one person is 3800
australian dollars if you convert this
number into u.s dollars it becomes
almost 3000 usd
that is a lot of money aside from that
here is an interesting fact the cost of
living in australia is almost 15 percent
greater than the america it ranks 10th
among the most expensive countries to
live in
leaving both uk and usa behind
the reserve funds you'll have to keep in
a closed bank account are almost 21 000
australian dollars which represents you
have the financial means to cover at
least one year's educational expenses in
australia budget wise this is not the
ideal choice for students with financial
restrictions that is the reason why we
have australia as the 4th contender
next up on our list is united kingdom
as mentioned earlier 16 universities in
uk rank among top global universities
the university of oxford university of
cambridge imperial college london
are the top universities that rank among
top 10 global universities besides that
these colleges have been around since
the middle ages bearing a significant
history of world education that is why
the united kingdom has been ranked
number one globally for the quality of
education and facilities the uk has the
best educational system globally
comprised of undergraduate postgraduate
and doctoral degrees ug courses are
designed to help learners gain practical
exposure after three years of
undergraduate courses learners can
pursue a master's degree the one year
master's course offer more in-depth
study for particular subject that makes
learners eligible for high paying jobs
and promotions
the next factor is budget as you must
know the uk is one of the most expensive
countries to live in the tuition fee in
uk lie around an average of thirteen
thousand fifty euros whereas living
expenses are around ten thousand three
hundred and eight euros that means the
blocked account fund for a year's
expense will be the sum of both these
figures which turns out to be almost
twenty 000 us dollars
the country that holds second rank on
our list is united states
according to the report of
educations.com the united states has
been ranked second worldwide for the
quality of education
mit stanford harvard the university of
chicago and the university of
pennsylvania are the top five american
universities ranking among the top 15
institutions globally
for decades the u.s has rained supreme
as the world's most popular study abroad
destination the country's prestigious
institutions dominate global university
rankings attracting students from across
the world with an appetite for academic
excellence
according to the project atlas report
1.2 million plus international students
reside in united states the reason
behind that is the immigration policies
of country and cultural acceptance in
the u.s international students can stay
and work for 12 months after completing
their studies further students who go
for stem education this duration is 24
months indians are the largest
beneficiary for h-1b visas more than 60
percent of these visas are issued to the
indian community which is a great deal
for the indian community
now coming to the budget to study in
america the living expenses and tuition
fee are quite higher here you'll have to
pay around 35 331 us dollars on average
to get into the university program
also the average living cost is around
18 000 us dollars which is quite high
too
however many students prefer the usa
since the job opportunities here are
quite lucrative and as high as you can
get many students cite that they fulfill
their education loans within two to
three years of time span
this indicates high returns on
investment in mediocre time
on that note let's move towards the
first country on our list germany
germany has always been among the top
global destinations for students across
the globe
because the german-speaking people have
been an inseparable part of world's
greatest invention in both arts and
sciences practically every academic area
has a long and exceptional heritage of
success stories here in germany
furthermore germany has abolished all
tuition costs for both national and
international students making education
more accessible
the top 5 public institutions offering
pre-education in germany are technical
university of munich university of
heddelberg lmu munich free university
berlin and humboldt university
there are 430 plus public universities
in germany that offer education at no
cost choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more but
does it imply you don't have to pay a
single penny to these german
universities
well the answer is no
there are other fees that german
university charge let's look into the
entire cost structure to understand that
the universities will charge you
approximately 500 to 600 euros per
semester for administrative expenditures
typically referred to as semester
contribution these fees cover
contribution charges travel expenses and
student union fees now let's talk about
living expenses the living cost in
germany is around 861 euros per month
it's a ballpark figure cities like
munich could be a little more expensive
and cities like berlin could be little
cheaper but on an average if you take a
number like 850 euros per month then it
could be a good average to work with
if you break this expense you'll find 50
percent of the sum going towards rent so
perhaps you can take up shared student
accommodation to reduce these charges
next higher percentage of the amount
would lead you towards food and
groceries and the remaining amount will
be going for internet charges stationary
etc
this german living cost is much cheaper
in comparison to neighbouring uk
countries such as france england or
netherlands or even united states of
america
the next benefit on our list is that you
need to keep a relatively lower amount
in your blocked bank account and let me
explain that to you
when you go to study in germany you need
to apply for national visa this visa has
number of different requirements and one
of the requirement is to place a sum of
money in a block bank account
these funds serve as a proof that you
have the financial means to cover at
least one year's living expenses
since there is no tuition fee in germany
this amount is significantly lower
you'll just have to show the amount
summing up one year's living expenses
such as rent internet food etc
you will have to open this block bank
account as soon as you get your
university acceptance letter or you can
also open this account in your home
country before you plan to take off for
germany
keeping inflation in consideration
the mandatory amount required in the
block bank account for studying in
germany as of january 1 2022 is 10 332
euros for an entire year or 861 euros
for a month candidate would have to keep
a little more than the said amount as
the bank would levy a service charge on
the student opening a block bank account
in germany the money stored in the block
account should ideally cover a student's
accommodation living expenses and even
transportation past charges
the third benefit we have on our list is
excellent infrastructure and facilities
that germany offers
higher education in germany consists of
three different types of institutions
universities universities of applied
sciences technical arts film and music
colleges
and most of those universities date from
the middle ages bearing the significant
tradition of qualitative education and
prominent names in various academic
disciplines
according to the official statistics of
2018 there are 429 recognized
universities in germany out of which 106
are among the list of globally ranked
universities
some of them have been ranked among the
world's best universities consistently
five of highest ranking universities in
germany are technical universities of
munich
dude with max milan university munich
heddelberg university
kashule institute of technology and
humboldt university berlin
germany as a whole place great value on
education and this is reflected in the
high quality teaching seen in country
international students can experience
the excellent quality of the education
on offer through english language driven
courses
degree courses are constantly updated to
meet the changing business world
students are given the opportunity to
utilize cutting-edge technology and the
latest research to ensure they are ready
to enter the world of work after
graduation
the fourth benefit of studying in
germany is that you are allowed to work
for part-time opportunities as per
german law international students with
student visa are allowed to work for 120
full days or 240 half days during the
year
when the semester is on you can work for
20 hours a week
whereas during vacations you can work
full time you will not require any type
of approval for this you can
automatically work for 20 hours a week
the moment you have a national visa for
a student
the part-time job opportunities revolve
around the store and restaurant shifts
language tutoring field interviewing or
a call center industry however you will
be required to master the german
language to get these interactive jobs
let's look at the remuneration
the minimum wage in germany is 9 euros
per hour but you get up to 15 to 18
euros per hour if you work as a call
center employee or operations assistant
looking at the 20 hours a week you could
earn up to 800 euros a month which would
sufficiently take care of your living
cost
also you could keep in mind that if you
earn more than 450 euros a month you'll
have to pay taxes and social security
contributions
and since you'll be working as a student
these charges will pan out to be quite
minimal
the fifth benefit on our list is better
job prospects
as you might know germany is the fourth
largest economy in the world after the
united states china and japan
also it is the largest economy in the
eastern european continent
because of that there are plenty of jobs
available for international students
with technical expertise
however to get the jobs you are required
to have german language proficiency
be one of language proficiency is the
bare minimum before you can look out for
any permanent job
let's talk about sectors that produce
maximum job opportunities in germany
the first one is information technology
as you know the world is gravitating
towards completely virtualization since
covet pandemic the requirements for it
experts in germany has increased
exponentially
according to the survey there are around
124 000 open jobs for id professionals
in germany
that's why it is at the top of our list
the next sector that produces more jobs
in germany is engineering
particularly mechanical engineering and
automobile engineering are the
trailblazers that produce a pool of job
opportunities you can also find abundant
jobs related to the electronics robotics
and chemical engineering sectors the
renewable power sector is another
growing industry that aims to develop
sustainable growth in germany and
another sector that has huge potential
is medical science
germany has always been a big
contributor to the global medical sector
hence
it is quite beneficial to explore this
field
the local companies that have
professionals for various sectors
are douche bank robert bosch
aliens finances siemens bmw wolfsbacon
autos hugo boss and adidas sportswear
and shoes
the top multinational companies that
operate and hire professionals in
germany are amazon google mckenzie and
company kpmg posh and mercedes-benz all
these companies have a significant
presence in germany and employ a large
number of professionals
however german universities have their
own career centers since these
universities are of global accreditation
and have strong ties with all local and
multinational companies and can help you
set your career on the track of growth
the next benefit of studying in germany
is the opportunity to settle down
typically after you finish your
university studies your student visa
will expire almost immediately even if
the visa was initially granted for
period longer than the period of your
degree after this expiration you'll be
eligible to apply for an 18-month work
visa during this period of 18 months
you'll have to search for permanent job
also you'll lose out on student benefits
such as subsidized health insurance and
free travel card
now as soon as you get a permanent job
you'll be eligible for part-time german
residence permit or eu blue card the
difference between these permits is
really as the name suggests the german
residence permit is restricted for the
jobs within germany whereas the eu blue
card allows you to move around between
the countries of eastern europe
however it is said that the german
residence card is prepared for better
long-term prospects within germany so
make sure you contemplate the pros and
cons of these two permits before
selecting one
in the next phase you will be eligible
for permanent german residence or a
permanent eu blue card depending on your
preference however you'll have to work
for a tenure of four years in germany to
apply for permanent residency
that's all we have about the benefits of
studying in germany however if you don't
have the required capital support to do
so we recommend you to look out for
global psw programs available online
these programs can help you accelerate
your career in the global market with
the least financial requirements
simplylearn offers one such management
program in collaboration with iu germany
you can now get access to the best that
iu has to offer study on campus build an
international management career and get
an opportunity to work in germany with
this master of business administration
mba program with iu germany and london
south bank university lsba you can
become a global management industry
leader
furthermore after successful completion
of this course you will be able to
launch a career in german corporations
with an 18 month long post study work
visa
here are a few highest paying
opportunities that you can get in
germany after finishing this accredited
mba program
the average base salary for finance
professionals in germany range around
almost 89 000 euros which pan out to be
75 lakh rupees in india
the base salary for marketing
professionals is almost 65
600 euros having an equivalence of
almost 54 lakh indian rupees
the next mba specialization that is
business analytics also has fruitful
salaries starting from 60 000 euros
the fourth one is the operations and
logistic salaries starting from a base
pay of 72 000 euros
and finally human resources
professionals in germany can earn up to
50 000 euros having equivalence around
42 lakh indian rupees
all these numbers mentioned above are
quite fruitful compared to the salaries
in other developing countries so
thinking about this program is worth a
while that's all we have for today
thank you for watching this video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you